my name is Brian Stevenson and on a
lawyer an advocate and an activist for
ending mass incarceration and creating
racial justice in the marital job
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I've been trying to say something about
our criminal justice system whenever
you're talking about a violation of
basic human rights a violation of basic
human dignity your first requirement is
to make sure people see the humanity of
the people who are experiencing these
injuries
this country we don't talk about slavery
we don't talk about lynching we don't
talk about segregation we don't want to
talk about racial bias in our criminal
justice system if we're serious about
correcting the imbalance created by
decades of inequality and injustice we
have to do more than just be silent I've
been kinda space clapping about no
justice basically something about no
justice I think
[Music]
this country is very different today
than it was 40 years ago
in 1972 there were 300,000 people in
jails in prisons today there are 223
million million no your ruder the United
States now has the highest rate of
incarceration in the world we have 7
million people on probation and parole
and mass incarceration facing race
invasion let me change a world in poor
communities and communities of color
there is this despair their business
hopelessness that is being shaped by
these outcomes one out of three black
men between the ages of 18 and 30 is in
jail in prison on probation or parole
one out of 100 we have a green light
like
[Music]
I've been trying to say something about
our criminal justice system our system
isn't just being shaped in these ways it
seemed to be distorting around race
they're also distorted by poverty we
have a system of justice in this country
that treats you much better if you're
rich and guilty of a trattoria innocence
the opposite of poverty it's not well
the opposite of poverty is just
[Music]
I've been trying to say something about
marginal justices United States the only
country in the world when we set
thirteen year old children will be sure
that's the United States protecting the
world's ultimate those emotions that
suppress the United States the only
country in the world will resent your
old children to die in prison we have
life in prison without parole for kids
country on country in the world
we love innovation we love technology
we love creativity we love completely
but ultimately those reality
completely to our shadows by suffering
abuse degradation marginalization and
for me to the console necessary to
dissipate the two because ultimately we
are talking about the HP more hopeful
more committed more dedicated to the
basic challenges of living in a complex
world to me that means spending time
thinking and talking about the poor the
disadvantaged I have come to understand
and to believe that each of us is lower
than the worst thing we've ever done
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I think the character of any society its
commitment of justice its commitment to
the rule of law has to be evaluated not
by looking at how it treats the rich and
the powerful and the privileged but by
looking at how it treats the poor the
incarcerated the disfavored people
living in the margins of society our
response to them our relationship to
them reveals our true character I didn't
do something better waiting for people
in this country than what we've
experienced there's something more
genuinely free more genuinely equal more
genuinely just than what we've
experienced in this country and if we
desire it and we struggle for it we can
achieve
[Music]